[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
firefighters in northern california say
they're starting to gain control
over historic deadly wildfires that have
burned more than one million
acres they get control very soon one
fire casualty a bird sanctuary
that releases endangered california
rather condors into the wild
now this danger is likely to continue
for days as carter evans reports
the smoke from so-called fires is what
they call it is exposing firefighters to
more
long-term damage than ever before
fast-moving wildfires in northern
california have now destroyed more than
1400 homes and buildings
beating back flames in these
unpredictable conditions is already a
dangerous job for frontline crews
but researchers now say it could also
have lasting effects
on their health would you see a
community burning in a wildfire
what goes through your mind now the
level of exposures that these
firefighters are
are getting at these situations
extremely
toxic for long periods of time retired
captain tony stefani worked for the san
francisco fire department for
28 years before he was diagnosed with
kidney cancer
he started the san francisco
firefighters cancer prevention
foundation which funds research to study
the link between firefighters exposure
to toxins
and cancer we can't wait for that
latency period for 5 to 10
20 years down the line to see if these
men and women are contract
various forms of this you know insidious
disease
something has to be done about it now
captain matt alba who's been with the
san francisco fire department for 18
years
spent a week and a half at the camp fire
in paradise california
in 2018 the state's deadliest and most
destructive fire
killed 85 people and destroyed more than
18 thousand homes and buildings
the problem is this is a new realm for
firefighting
it doesn't necessarily cleanly meet
structural firefighting
and it doesn't cleanly meet wildland
firefighting
he urged stefani's organization to fund
a study analyzing blood and urine
samples
collected from dozens of firefighters
minutes after they left the front lines
we were starting to see a lot of members
with those coughs
headaches i couldn't help but think
about 911
and what all of those responders went
through
10 years after the incident early
results of that study released this week
show firefighters had a mixture of
chemical toxicants
and some heavy metals and levels higher
than those found in the general u.s
population
in some firefighters the level of pfas
chemicals
were two to five times higher than
levels in the general population
these are chemicals used to make
hundreds of household products water and
steam resistant
that are also linked to kidney and liver
cancers
researchers say the study is a red flag
for firefighters
and those who live near massive
wildfires
environmental health scientist mike
wilson says part of the problem at
wildfires
is the lack of breathing protection
urban firefighters use air tanks and
face masks to
safely breathe in a structure fire but
that's not feasible for wildland
firefighters
who often have to hike for miles and
work 12 to 24-hour shifts
wilson says some in the industry are now
working to develop
portable respirators that could
eventually be used in the field
it's incumbent upon us i would say as a
society
to ensure that they have all the tools
they need
to do their work effectively and safely
for cbs this morning carter evans
san francisco
such an important story there by carter
as we remember that
we learned that the chemicals in the
smoke could be as dangerous as the
flames that those firefighters are
fighting and that those cancer deaths
for firefighters
should be considered line of duty deaths
according to a lot of the research
that's emerging right now
very important story we're going to stay
with that one carter thank you very much